Alec Baldwin will face charges for his
role in the death of a filmmaker and
he's not the only person prosecutors are
charging in the case The Accidental
fatal shooting of cinematographer Helena
Hutchins on the set of the western movie
rust dominated the news cycle in late
2021. over a year later the case is far
from over on the contrary legal
consequences over the tragic turn of
events have only just begun at the heart
of the rust tragedy as actor Alec
Baldwin who is the person alleged to
have fired the supposedly harmless prop
gun that killed her chins and injured
director Joel Souza despite that in the
month's sensor shooting occurred Baldwin
has publicly made Moves have been
responsibility for the shooting on
essentially anyone but him
someone is responsible
for what happened and I can't say who
that is but I know it's not me on
January 19th more than a year after
denying responsibility in an interview
with George Stephanopoulos it was
announced that Alec Baldwin as well as
sethamura Hannah Gutierrez read will be
charged with involuntary manslaughter
over the rust set shooting interestingly
one person that won't be charged as
assistant director Dave Halls who also
reportedly handled the loaded weapon on
the day of hutchin's death Paul's house
reportedly agreed to a plea deal in his
own legal proceedings and received a
six-month sentence of probation in
announcing the charges against Baldwin
and Gutierrez read New Mexico officials
also released some important information
about the state of the gun that fired
the Fatal shot an FBI forensics reports
has found that the Cox gun couldn't be
fired without pulling the trigger until
the gun malfunctioned due to an internal
breakage this calls into question
Baldwin's earlier claims that he didn't
pull the trigger to make the gun go off
well the trigger wasn't pulled I didn't
pull the trigger so you never pull the
trigger no no no I would never point a
gun to anyone and pull a trigger at them
never despite the criminal charges a
post-mortem investigation signed by the
chief medical investigator of New Mexico
concluded that there was no evidence
that the gun had been intentionally
loaded with live ammunition it also
maintained that there was no evidence
that anyone involved with the rust
production had an overt intention to
cause bodily harm the report read in
part based on all available information
including the absence of obvious intent
to cause harm or death the manner of
death is best classified as accident the
news of charges being filed in the case
led to quick responses from
representatives of the parties involved
on the victim's side the Hutchins family
attorney Brian J panish released a
statement that praise the officials
actions in filing charges according to
that statement it is a comfort to the
family that's in New Mexico no one is
above the law Baldwin's Camp has also
commented on the recent developments
through a statement released by the
actor's lawyer Luke Nichols responding
to the decision to file criminal charges
against Baldwin the statement read this
decision distorts Helena hutchin's
tragic death and represents a terrible
miscarriage of Justice Mr Baldwin had no
reason to believe there was a live
bullet in the gun or anywhere on the
movie Set he relied on the professionals
with whom he worked who assured him the
Gunn did not have life rounds we will
fight these charges and we will win
[Music]